Los Angeles International Airport was
the scene overnight of organized chaos
the world's fourth biggest airport is
undergoing a massive swap of terminals
15 airlines are relocating over three
very busy nights Kris Van Cleave is at
LAX where he got special access to this
complicated operation Kris good morning
good morning and so far so good here
just hours ago this was a spirit ticket
counter Delta is paying for the entire
move it's part of the Airlines 1.9
billion dollar investment in expanding
its operation here at LAX and for the
people actually doing the move it's a
race against time they only have about
five hours to make it happen between
when the last flight landed last night
and the first one took off this morning
more than 220,000 fliers a day pass
through LAX but as night fell it was the
airlines who were on the move
listen up there's a lot of stuff going
on tonight from terminals 2 & 3
everything must go just follow the signs
as 15 airlines travel across the airport
to make way for Delta to move in over
the three nights it's been a 13-month
planning session Ranjan goswami is
overseeing the move for delta why not
stretch it out and not try to do it all
at once it's really hard to operate an
operation as large as Delta's over the
course of four weeks you just can't do
that with almost 200 flights a day
outside planes needed to be towed to
their new homes along with all the gear
on the tarmac inside the ticket counters
kiosks signs and computers have to be
carefully wrapped boxed and loaded on a
moving vans only to be unpacked minutes
later
construction projects are going on
simultaneously as nearly 1,000 signs
have been changed including as you
arrive at the airport we went from I
think geminal 3 to terminal 4 and now
we've got to go to terminal 6 but flyer
confusion is expected hundreds of
volunteers and shuttle buses are on
standby I have a 6:20 a.m. flight out of
here and they're saying that you're
supposed to be at the airport there's
three hours that means I have to get
about one o'clock in the morning that's
one of the volunteers they're helping
with the confusion Delta for example is
operating at at least four terminals
today so fliers do need some help there
this is unprecedented move being called
the largest airline terminal swap in
history so getting it right is really
important considering tensions between
flyers and airlines have been running
very high of late Gail yep you got to
pack your patience triple time when you
go the airport these days thank you very
much Chris Van Cleve